My name is Rossteen Salehzadeh and I'm from
Ann Arbor Michigan. I graduated from Washtenaw
Christian Academy in 2010, and I'm a Politics
major at Hillsdale College. This spring I'm
interning in United States Senator Deb Fischer's
office as part of the Washington Hillsdale
Internship Program. The Washington Hillsdale
Internship Program, we
call it WHIP for short, we bring anywhere between ten
to twenty students a semester out to DC. They
take two or three classes and they intern
on the hill, at the Heritage
Foundation, really anywhere they want to.
When we find somebody coming out of college
who has some practical real world experience,
especially experience that applies to what
we do, it really sets them apart. Washington
is one of those places that kids can learn
a lot and gain a lot just from being hear
a few moths. And in that since, coming here
and having that interning experience I guarantee
will be life changing.